hi there steve kaufman here again with
the seventh in my series of secrets to
successful language learning i won't
review
uh secrets one to six because i can't
remember them here right off the bat and
i'll jump right into the seventh it's
maybe the most difficult thing for
people to
achieve
and that is
take charge of your own language
learning become an independent language
learner i believe that only independent
language learners are successful and
convert themselves into fluent speakers
of another language there are millions
of people who go to class
and
most of them don't achieve success
unless they take their learning out of
the classroom and pursue the language
following some of the secrets some of
the methods that i've suggested in this
series like spending enough time on
their own outside the classroom pursuing
things of interest to them listening and
reading
uh
interacting with the language in ways
that they like and developing the
ability to notice
um
making sure they have the right tools
being patient with their learning all
these things that i've
described in these uh this series of
videos are the attributes of an
independent learner you have to become
independent uh
i hear people all the time saying you
know why does this language uh
go this way is this right or is that
right uh what does this mean
i consider myself an independent
language learner having learned 11 and
now work in my 12th language i never ask
myself those questions either i have a
translation handy or i can figure it out
by looking words up in the online
dictionary
or i let it go and i know that
eventually this pattern these words will
start to make sense to me
if i want to look up
something to do with grammar it's easy
enough to do today
just by googling i can see verb tables
or non-declension tables uh in any
language with you know two clicks um i
have a little grammar book that i
occasionally leave through in the
different languages
but i don't expect that any teacher has
to teach it to me i can access the
language and learn from it and explore
it on my own and i don't need structure
and and that's essentially how we
structured link we do divide our our
content our lessons into levels of
difficulty but within each level of
difficulty you're free to explore
whichever content strikes your fancy
and uh some people have trouble with
this uh sort of unstructured way of
learning but that's how people learn in
real life so if you haven't already done
so
i would invite you uh to come to link
lingq.com and explore what what we have
done what we have created for the
independent language learner and i look
forward to meeting you there so thank
you for listening to this series and
goodbye for now
you